c'est uniquement mus avec les mâles
hockey part c'est un peu je vois pas
d'autres étapes
[Musique]
j'avais pas arriver de nombreuses fois
mais deux fois face à des taureaux
légendaire qui sont très connu dans le
milieu on a les appelle les toro de
miura ou de palaces et les taureaux
portugais qu'ils ont cette
caractéristique d'être d'abord très
grand et moi je suis assez petit et donc
du coup d'avoir des comportements
difficiles à canaliser
j'avoue que j'ai très mal dormi et le
journal ou si ça a été très compliqué je
suis sorti indemne mais j'ai eu très
peur c'est ma dernière corrida
c'était en septembre 2012 à nîmes
j'avais fait le choix d'arrêter un en
avant parce que je sentais que
j'arrivais au bout de mon chemin de
toreros autant avec le public que dans
la relation et le plaisir que j'avais et
là c'était vraiment plein de souvenirs
par l'histoire que je laissais 20 ans de
vie derrière moi tout ça du fer que j'ai
pas dû être très concentré ou assez
concentré et assez performant dans la
tohu dans le combat avec les taureaux
[Musique]
j'ai suivi mon papa est dans sa passion
qui était allé aux arènes devant des
candidats
je les accompagne et je suis allé dans
les élevages et jeune j'avais eu 8 9 10
ans quelque chose comme ça et puis un
jour on m'a proposé d'essayer avec une
cape de donner quelques basses à une
petite vache et là c'est devenu ma
propre passion plus était celle de mon
père et à ce moment là j'ai décidé de
continuer la boucle le plus longtemps
possible je suis tombé amoureux petit à
petit que cette passion-là et un jour il
a fallu faire le chantre les études et
cette vie de toreros et c'est à ce
moment-là que j'ai tranché j'avais 20
ans maintenance sur les réseaux sociaux
françois des menaces en direct en
commentaire des choses comme ça alors
pas énormément mais quelques-unes j'ai
aussi des boutiques où j'ai reçu des
détails on m'a cassé des vitrines
boutique des choses comme ça et puis on
a reçu des courriers on a été plusieurs
à avoir des courriers piégés avec des
lames de rasoir donc très dangereux
peut-être eu des tentatives même de
d'assassinât on sait pas si les lames
sont empoisonnés ou non ça s'est
heureusement bien passé pour tout le
monde parce que c'est pas moi qui les ai
reçus directement
elles sont arrivées dans les boutiques
et sont des salariés qui les ont reçues
qui heureusement ne se sont pas blessés
mais mais ça aurait pu être très grave
être torero parfois il ya des situations
très désagréable beaucoup plus pour
l'entourage et les amis que pour nous
[Musique]